let's talk about Jennifer Lawrence who
was actually in California for Amy
Schumer star-studded top secret wedding
and then headed to washington DC to
promote her new movie red sparrow but
there's another event that has j-law
feeling left out
you missed kris Jenner's Valentine's
party had Kardashian's Kanye and karaoke
and I'm in Washington DC it's unbalanced
Kris by the way you didn't give me an
invite but we'll talk about that later
yeah maybe next year Jen but we like to
think the vodka party we had together
yesterday was a pretty good substitute
are you holding up since our vodka
really messed me up how are you holding
up pretty good pretty good I'm
Australian don't insult my you know
ability to hold it down it gave me a
choice die or become it's better you'll
be trained to his psychological
manipulation Jay laws new spy thriller
reunites her with Hunger Games director
Francis Lawrence
it's her grittiest role today recruited
by Russian intelligence and trained to
commit some dastardly deeds in the name
of country
I'd like to think that it would be
harder for her to say yes to a movie
like this with somebody else and
somebody who's a stranger it certainly
made it easier to communicate about some
of the content the tortuous sequences
who do you think had it worse
you were Joel I definitely had it worse
I was being sprayed with cold water and
my arms were tied did you see the angle
at which my arms were tied not where to
sit there basically get tickled by a
fake Choi sorry I'm tired
[Music]